ela usa levar isso vai estar frente a
mim eu também beck e destina o pessoal
estamos aqui como vocês puderam ver pelo
título hoje nós vamos então revelar toda
a verdade toda a informação oculta
nesta série de conectar o jogador logo
porque como vocês sabem muita gente tem
as suas dúvidas e muita gente pergunta
se na questão seria é e será que eu me
ferro mesmo oferta não é uma delícia
fazer um por trás da cena é exato nós
vamos contar tudo o que aconteceu e o
porquê deste tipo de vídeos ser muito
lentamente tempo às vezes é de seis em
seis meses e eo porque isso acontece o
que é verdade eo que é mentira assim
porque o vi que algumas coisas feita e
eu vou lá também vai rolar
espero que vocês não fiquem chateados
mas nós vamos revelar toda a verdade é
que inspire portanto vejam até o fim
porque vai ser importante nós vamos
desistir é todos os comentários jogador
do uol e vamos lançar o desafio pessoal
se vocês assistirem o vídeo até o fim
se derem online subscreverem muito
espancarem com os vossos amigos fizeram
tudo que vocês têm que fazer se vocês
fizerem isso tudo
amanhã além eu posso já um comitê
julgador do uol ou um como está um amigo
do isso ninguém pode sempre dias antes a
proposta não eu já sem o pino baixá lo
amanhã portanto acho que é mais provável
de sair como está o nome dois porque o
que vai na área em casa posso citar a
vontade livre e consciente de que vai
fazer com que o pessoal tá aí a meta a
meta se inscrevam de chile que vai ser o
filho eu vim e amanhã e saiu como é que
está como está o nível 2 é pessoal que
eu tenho aqui pra falar pra você escutar
frame empresário homem de sucesso besni
tuber construiu uma plataforma por vocês
aquela moto que se tenha um canal é
minha empresa eu posso ficar roxa
pessoal eu criei uma plataforma online
onde vocês podem entrar 11 catarineta é
só vocês podem entrar lá a plataforma
ainda está em causa está o não seja
falta um dia para ela sair vai ser
sábado e como é que vocês podem
interagir com esta plataforma vocês
podem entrar lá e vocês podem ter acesso
a conteúdo exclusivo mil fotos vídeos
coisas que eu faço ap com desculpas o
dante ocultas que ninguém sabe oque
sombra você anda que o começo a conteúdo
exclusivo e toda a gente pode
não há pessoal toda a gente pode entrar
do brasil pessoal de portugal o pessoal
da escola ou frança todos podem entrar e
de estarem lá e pra vocês terem se
escondido exclusivas vão ter que pegar
um gol meu dinheiro agora a sério esse
conteúdo exclusivo ao muito a pena mesmo
e é muito barato vocês podem fazer o
pagamento com o telemóvel com paul
carton créditos forem mais novas pessoas
dos nossos pais mas eu garanto que só
vocês um símbolo tem muito lá tem coisa
um grande prêmio por estar brinquedos eu
vou usar a mesma coisa portanto
completamente a pena e se gaste dinheiro
vai mostrar a minha vida senhor promotor
e vocês podem saber quem é mesmo fã se
vai ter acesso tem que continuar
portanto saiu em que a descrição pessoal
espero um dia vai ser de sábado já
amanhã e plataforma oficial só está
completamente licenciada está dentro da
lei tudo se tinha direito então vocês
podem ir lá com segurança dos alimentos
o link de inscrição taí o primeiro em
que já se fez em falta um dia e maxxi
uma plataforma é de agora e do daer e
pra vocês digitarem para entrarem lá não
é obrigatório o pagamento o que vocês
podem entrar à vontade podem registar
mas para terem algum tipo de acesso
contínuo específica e sim tem que pagar
só o ser é muito barata em meio à cpi e
iremos buscar gol - o projeto de lei só
com esse dinheiro é menos bom que vocês
metem no fórum landi
olha o bom isso e se vocês não estarão
vocês podem sempre cancelar portanto
escolher você já sabe é mulher livro é
tão pessoal vamos exigir que todos os
vídeos de como irritar um jogador logo e
à medida que nós vamos vendo os vídeos
nós vamos reagir e otimismo os vídeos
porque já nem me lembro que eu fiz ao
ppe eo já nem se lembra como é que
exigiu isso vamos guardar o meu jogador
já negocia com uma câmera vai poder ser
feito muito mal
amo mas por dentro desses vídeos tem
coisas que nós mostramos tem coisas que
são falsas as coisas que são verdadeiras
coisas que aconteceram com sejam salvas
e vamos falar isso agora e vamos lá para
não vai tomar a droga em lei e sinto-me
normal e outro aqui confira o vídeo do
outro livre e sei que foi uma das
piscinas não mas é que já tem que
regular uma coisa é que há uma pequena
mentira por trás deste vídeo então a
primeira mentira que nós vamos falar que
não era uma mentira é uma mentirinha
pequenina porque era mesmo preciso fazê
lo eu pensei em fazer este vídeo e tudo
que eu fiz ao ppe aconteceu
realmente eu não sabia o que acontecer
comportamento improviso mas o que
aconteceu aqui foi o pib já era um
jogador habitual do leeds mas nisso e eu
não ia jogar então tive mesmo forçar o
piauí já pronto eo piris na mesma
potência não queria ficar hoje o caso
não vai estragar o vídeo é então eu
próprio tive que demitir o bip olha eu
quero que jogue com flashes porque eu
quero fazer um vídeo tu não vais saber o
que quer mas eu preciso dos jogos porque
eu vou fazer um vídeo então esta pequena
parte de dani eu dizer que não sabia que
estava gravada ela entenda
foi uma pequena mentira região porque
era preciso e e tudo responde agora a
seguir eu não sei o que aconteceu
portanto só questão de um severo lo para
fazer o vídeo essa parceria e pronto foi
uma pequena mentira nós mas para
continuar a fazê lo já no quem tinha
piloto caminho opina o menino nesta
altura de repudiar o picasa deu e agora
principal estudo comecei a trabalhar
aqui mas em outubro
eu vou te ensinar as coisas todas mas
começaram a fazer tudo e nessa altura eu
estava tinindo para computador
eu sou teu cabelo não nega nem magro de
casa pega perguntada sobre um trio não
teve esta rua aristides gota d'água foi
o teste foi o direito com prazo casaco
dele na frente na etapa desse oferta eu
sair eles não lembro que meu estilo de
vida mudou completamente desde ontem o
nosso continente sempre muito lenta
porque muitos já não têm casa na altura
pensei que era muito rápido de busca
a primeira coisa que é cara do peão de
tentar fingir que não sabia que eu ia
o vídeo é a primeira coisa que o ps não
tem fita cola problema que eu tenho no
pc é que eu não conseguir refrigerar
como torcedor teve uma caixa de ano e eu
dei essa caixa é incompatível ou seja
quem for fazer mas nós quer obter aqui o
convite na e outra legislação desde
sempre desde sempre
eu chamo pi no canal deu e em todos os
vídeos de 60 m este vírus específicos de
conectar um jogador igual eu sempre
chamei de miguel monteiro não tem mãe
que esta personagem que é o nome de eu
ea lu não real e arouca na altura título
esse poder muito mais graça por milhão
montante monteiro e ela escolheu 19
synthpop op e era uma coisa pequena
então amiga monteiro graça quando cobriu
toda a gente já de monarquia se a
montanha era inimigo
nada contra os meninos a brincadeira com
perguntas e respostas que foi 2009 que
mede essa banana médico aguenta jogar o
que vem já vai estar frio comigo tentou
brincar pintar diz ainda que desde que
eu tinha uma coisa opção também gostava
muito era nas partidas que fazia do
jogador do osso também ranking ou não
todas as partidas pessoal é ranking
porque a mais uma vez eu digo só eu
creio que eu sabia que eu ia gravar mas
não sabia que ele ia gravar e neste jogo
foi banido ea eu fiquei eu fui menino
não aliás em todos os jogos e houve um
show qualquer em todos se usa você pode
fazer um novo hábito fazer de novo eu
fiquei bonito durante cinco jogos e
jogos que tenha que esperar 20 minutos
nakheel está um jogador bom é bom não é
de vocês
o psol já deu o percebo eu tenho que
ficar 20 minutinhos aqui ou só de tipo
de fila de espera para entrar na fila de
espera para entrar no jogo
só nesse campo as equipes de busca que
buscam um castigo sem que este tenha
equilíbrio deste grupo tá louco mas
várias fontes tem que estar ligado ao
pcp que o ps tem fita cola
assim deve ter início na praça central
a virada que o pac custará por james
joyce e foi isso que eu tenho aquela
caixa a chuva não gostou que a
temperatura suficiente vence isso olha
mas todo jogador só entrega simbólica do
tua mãe que taxa custará lesionado e aí
o adriano jogar bola
miguel monteiro girl montanha sérgio
bateria muito letais ano não haverá sol
e milhares estão a trabalhar para isto
não tá bom foco não eu fui inspirada na
zona dos beckham não em mim pode fazer
caixas mas hoje o fim da missão é time
câmera mostrando a cara que na história
não votei nesse caso assim o santos
partiu rápido no edital joão no porto
não o partido com as torradas com super
com super cola não cola aqui mas isso
foi isso o que pensa na frente fui lá
falei isso foi oferecido cerca 8 não só
toda a dor do freio em toda é o todo o
cheiro de vídeo na pancadaria onde o
piloto e um de uma top tudo verdadeiro é
real e efetivo uma vez que prudente com
um chapéu de chuva vamos ver a lista
aqui que eu fiquei com uma negra ac
comandou negra e também votar em cuba
porque não joga em casa mas confio muito
hoje foi essa parte foi dos que a
empresa quer conectar o jogador ou três
ou quatro fui nem eu conhecia o fogo que
como a nokia estava vermelha que ficou
ficou noturno seja total desafio
chapéu-de-chuva [ __ ]
será que ganhou o jogo limpo na
descrição exatamente porque foi
protegido isso acontece pois é parcelar
o final porque porque no final do vídeo
diz assim olha vai fazer-se uma cena que
pode custar o final do vídeo o ano
anterior ou seja passa no mesmo dia que
o meu mas no final e não pode o final e
assim também exclui visualizações e
goiânia 7 foi todo o corpo e eu disse
sim emp eu preciso fazer este vídeo hoje
eu quero fazer este filho porque eu sei
que vai ser engraçado
então olha mais compactuar aqui que o
qual com esta pequena mentira hockey e
isto pode colocar o sujeito desse mesmo
vídeo no canal e assim eu consigo várias
pessoas até então tinha conseguido
ajudar
então de certa forma uma parceria e foi
isso que aconteceu então tá explicado
jogando ou um fogo desde então os outros
para evitar os vídeos então esqueceu a
que muda com muita mentira muito é
verdade que em iporá agora meu deus ou
atento empenhado agora ela como está o
jogador doou 2 foi aqui onde eu comecei
a fazer vídeos de experiência e jets e
31 brincava com fogo é a temática com
fiéis ruim dos 10 ao assumir em 27 e ver
um desta vez que eu já estava mais frio
por causa do meu peso porque não come
mais a atenção neste nível é que sim eu
não sabia que eu ia começar a fazer aqui
o vídeo eu apanho de manhã já no bairro
parque do sol o trabalhada
straka pra jogar louco com a doux
aprenda a usar o comando é bombeiro 2014
estão aproximando pois mas o que
acontecer um desvio já em pisco no cubo
e número de bi/cc olha o filme histórias
num planeta existia coca-cola voadora
ópera o melhor pro melhor procurando na
área
até hoje o peter que o posto que o levou
a aceitar que enfrentará a frança a quem
não não mesmo que eu não estou a pagar é
talvez o sol
eu sei que tem várias coisas que uma
selecção de autor da proposta josé
augusto na estátua minha história lá
lavar desculpa aí pedi desculpa desculpa
olha eu não entendo que nunca entra e
acho que aqui também é minha eu venho
aqui o próprio fiquei chateado porque
esta câmara apesar de poder era uma
câmera nova então eu quero ter chegado à
câmara o que é uma galera amanhã em
braga estão aí e estamos a falar toda a
verdade ea verdade é que eu estava
realmente irritado conteúdo
josé não percebi minha maneira mas sei
que estão aqui era era minha câmera não
interessa só acreditava mas tudo e
chegar a minha câmera é qualquer coisa
se sobrepõe no ranking e tullow que tu
não podes perder o arranque do local aí
a mulher escolher qual foi edson mulher
não é instrumento é daqui pra frente
neste momento quero fazer a mulher de
bomba e outro lado da verdade mas falar
então das suas cuecas não sei lá eu
nunca vou falar o que o código pin do
telemóvel de um ataque pessoal é aí
vocês eles foram aqui vocês têm um
elemento que foi muito vir ao conseguir
o dinheiro que foi aí é e e
comportamental pode falar que é verdade
só que eu não é verdade é que o texto
não é verdade não é verdade não é
verdade que nem percebeu isto aqui o
vídeo aí eu percebi rapidamente tu
fizeste assim então vou explicar não só
lá vou explicar aquilo que aconteceu foi
não haver aquela coisa eu tenha em cima
da mesa aquilo era uma legging os verdes
que eu tinha encomendado de uma loja que
não tinha enviado não eu nem sequer
encomenda e os enviaram para eu abrir
algum país eu já nem muita coisa nessa
altura o que estava em um bar muito na
altura era os vídeos do resende
com o e bay ae mesmo que não sabia que
era um saco não não e não alterou o
resultado a bomba muito com a moeda
móvel pessoal aproveitar e fazer vídeos
com a moeda 60 e nessa altura eu fiz uma
coisa inconscientemente eu fiz uma
primeira virar uma vida excluiu
completamente e fiz foi me com tinta o
que aconteceu quase todas e nathan bell
'quando você cair a foto com um produto
específico que era para chegar eu tinha
que fazer a escolha do produto não sabe
o que é que até a imagem não sabia o que
era mais visualizações
então eu só porque aquelas legs puxei e
entre 27 e 31 que eu pensei foi ok com
as pessoas não vão saber o que é que
isto é porque não dá pra perceber bem
pode ser que tem um tenho aquela quinlan
o bichinho que será isso e vou entrar
foi esse o meu crescimento mas na altura
como a moeda estava ter muito ea moeda
sempre verde era uma coisa elástica eu
acho que o que aconteceu eo que acabou
por reconhecer mesmo foi que as pessoas
pensaram que eu tinha uma noiva na mão
supergigante alegre de que era um sonho
mas leva um tom pessoal acabou por
entrar ter muita visualização à toa
eu acho que me que 100 mil visualizações
por vídeo na altura sido o tipo 2
milhões de uma coisa fizeram o que
aconteceu é que eu não sou mais lenta
então o pessoal entrou e comentaram
todos e eu pensando que isso era a moeda
de volta fazendo clique dente
eu não sabia que estava a fazer uma
história muito bacana porque na altura
eu quero só ver o vídeo fogo que tem um
perfil e as leis pessoal gosta de graxa
coisas depois eu fiz o segundo nome é o
nome da minha empresa a igreja espírito
logo em seguida confessar um pouco doído
só eu não sei se vocês sabem mas é super
perigoso fazer isto porque quando uma
chama entrou em contacto com o cabelo o
pêlo do ser humano
peguei entretenimento fogo porque é
super inflamável então ela tem isso
nunca aproxima e uma chama do que meu
bem porque não começa a queimar assim é
louco
lagos e nona e sempre quando você quer
um tipo pelo mano chamou será pouco
agora imagina cheio de talento estudo se
o tema tinha já nem mesmo para o pt
volta porque estava com um miguel
monteiro como é que o faz vivo ainda 14
seu filho merece morrer eu deixei é que
aqui era o melhor software de verdade
sem comer bem é software mais tempo um
brinquedo quer só costuma ser mais
potente e ter mais força à noite não
estou agora só quero uma sorte assim
mais tempo um destino mesmo mas eu acho
que é uma coisa mas você 5 uma linha
fraca de produtos mas qualquer forma do
ir
vocês conseguem sentir a opção olha como
a sua idéia do sul é um sua não queimá
lo e acelerava o cantor mas você
consegue esse tempo só nessa altura
estava mesmo com muito mesmo
estava muito até mesmo a pensar que ele
manterá que o tempo aqui a nuca que se
não não eu isto está um ambiente mais
bem controlado é controlado eu estava a
fazer já agora é pessoal não esqueçam da
china que me inspira e subscrevemos
quiserem continuar a ver neste tipo de
vídeos já sabem como 31
deixei muito claro que amanhã pode ser o
começo estava um homem só não vai ser
com você com só vai vai apoiar eu sair
eu penso em particular a plataforma
também em primeiro em que a instituição
para a internet diz mesmo que elas a
apae e hoje ele está errado quando além
do cozinha
ao total a y vocês vão ver que ela tira
que eu começar um cheiro assim que o
ponto que parte é todo material que não
existe tipo possibilidade de ser
restituído na altura é mesmo material
que o meu sim sei que no caso era sempre
subsidiou o dia 6 com os noivos em que
eu tinha um rádio oxigénio que bateu o
ecrã ou seja não chovia ea altura eu
perdia eu ficava tipo 1 deu um coice não
e às vezes e às vezes neste último jogo
do futebol
que teve uma certa piada entre nós uma
piada interna que era quando o que
precisava de alguma coisa eu chegava pra
mim eu tô mesmo a precisar de um monitor
novo e eu e eu a proposta era sempre a
mesma
vamos fazer como estão jogando lá então
eu já sabia que eu lançava proposta
sempre que ele precisa ter uma coisa
nova
hoje tenho uma infantil também teremos
que comprar e não fizer isso ela não da
maneira que eu sentir a presença da
única
aqui fica o goleiro willian ainda tem
que fazer alguma coisa com esta máquina
gosta de brincar com esse tipo de coisas
não é porque eu tô possui uma grande
ideia era fazer isso aqui exatamente às
pode ter mais poderei saques eram
devidas agora lei já que nesta caixa que
não está assombrada para impedir mas
pode gastar porque eu convido os manos
ganhei nem de manhã entre o sublime não
é para mim não é possui me uma vez um
homem estava passando uma porta cometeu
disse assim eu posso ir passar o time
não merece o primeiro sai demônio sair e
antônio e sim porque o pessoal tava
dizer que eu andava a brincar com a
região estava a faltar ao respeito a
todo o pessoal religioso não é o caso
tanto que tudo o que é piada de tipo de
racismo aqui dentro deste vídeo estão
quando chamou guido preto o que eu digo
que o preto virou branco e sete piadas
são piadas entre nós porque obviamente
esse tipo de piada quando é ofensiva e
quando a pessoa sabe que vai ser a
ofensiva e é mau é mau isso acontecer
mas já conheço pinhais você chama de
preto à vontade e me leva a mal o seu
momento brincar à vontade com o que toda
a verdade
falta até 1 6 mi
o campeão roc realizados como tinha de
largar essa cadeira não existe miguel
monteiro bar quando consegue essa pinto
já não usa já seqüenciou que não
envergonhe peraí natureza com o milan
agora não agora é agora é puro agora
como kelvin com um só tênis marca só nec
também só o meu lado assim muito
dependente químico é carioca
quantas vezes eu usasse este ano vamos
ver quantas vezes ela que já foi de tudo
que toda a beleza e talento ponte era
ficar aqui chantal limpa não caiu nas
cuecas honra como é que tu com a queda
também de mitchell tem hoje eu sou gordo
não só que eu tenho que ter um negócio e
se já bem organizado para saber como é
que sendo uma menina que foi encontrada
não me coloco no lugar de antonio
callado caraças não digas estamos
pedindo é assunto já não é pra quem não
sabe se o avião não é que mesmo é e uma
mulher
o pessoal da minha idéia era analisar os
vídeos todos neste vídeo mas como o
youtube que os filhos vão ficar muito
grande e há muita conversa muita
regulação eu vou deixar isto para uma
série se vocês quiserem nós analisamos
como é que está o jogador do galo
conectar o jogador doou 2
ainda temos mais três podem acertar
antes eles ainda têm muito muito feliz e
eu vou te contar uma coisa estas
pequenas mentiras conveniência de vídeos
são pequenas medidas sim mas há muita
coisa ainda vai rolar nos outros vídeos
mas eu preciso perceber se vocês gostam
de ver isto se gosta de ver essa análise
se gostam de ver esta parte mais
verdadeira nossa né
portanto como tem muitos quiserem ver e
eu sim eu posso fazer um vídeo mais
longo vídeo tipo maior assim algo
irregular melhor este vídeo então só se
inspirem não esqueçam muito light muitas
subscrição muita visualiza são muito eu
entrar e sêmen foi cafu gilberto gil que
tal nunca tinha dúvidas mesmo tempo
roberta não esqueceu também pessoal da
plataforma metade o primeiro link de
inscrição está em causa da unifal idéia
só tu não tens por falta um dia ainda
teve que esperar mas eu tenho nesse
censo vai ser pessoal sábado às 18 horas
tarlá bom sabor brasil e 81 souber me
ajudar fãs que já tenha aplicação pode
ser antes mas vai ter que pagar a mesma
coisa mas calma negócio a negócio que
tem coragem da casa fora de brincadeiras
já sabem primeiro ninguém na descrição
apoio muito que o canal e agora vamos
apostar mais vidas já sabe amanhã como
estava com um amigo se depois decidiu
continuar o meu amigo já expliquei bem
até a próxima